[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on 8th of June I'm Cindy
Yu the spectator's assistant editor and
your host for this week
coming up on the show
as Harry has been in London this week
for the phone hacking trial against the
mirror Freddie gray writes the cover
piece for the magazine about Harry's
lonely Crusade the first Royal to take
the stand this Century has the prince
been badly advised by his lawyers I'll
be joined by Freddie gray and former Sun
journalist Neil Wallace
Rishi C9 has arrived in Washington for a
state visit with President Biden sunac
clearly wants to be Biden's best friend
but it's that love reciprocated Katie
boss has a story
and is the World Health Organization
Beyond repair that's what Christopher
Snowden suggests in the magazine this
week from cozying up to authoritarian
states to release ingressionable Health
advice the who might well have lost its
way Christopher joins the show
is now being revealed to that during the
pandemic the UK and U.S governments both
worked with social media companies to
clamp down on what they could
misinformation about covid-19 but what
costs of freedom of speech does that
come at author and journalist Michael
schellenberger has just begun a
worldwide campaign against censorship he
joins me on the show
and finally Oxfam released an odd video
this week seemingly to directly
reference JK Rowling and calling her a
Turf I'll be hearing all about what that
word means and why Oxfam would care
about it Helen Joyce the journalist
joins me
before we get going thanks to our
sponsors can Accord genuity wealth
management for supporting the show
canacord are experienced wealth planners
and investment managers who offer
unwavering support in challenging times
visit can do wealth.com for more
information
and if you enjoy spectator TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode
first up for the cover story this week
Freddie gray has taken a look at Harry's
loan Crusade Prince Harry is taking the
stand against the mirror which he
accuses of hacking his phone it's the
first time a royal has taken the
standing over a century and the prince
seems to be very much out of touch has
he been badly advised Freddie joins me
now together with journalist Neil
Wallace former deputy editor of the news
of the world
Freddie and Neil thank you so much for
joining spectator TV now Freddie you've
written our cover piece this week about
Harry's stand or Harry's Crusade as it
were what have you made of it or was it
has he been convincing I think it's been
very embarrassing for him and quite
humiliating I think the first day was
the Tuesday a day late uh but it was
obviously couldn't miss his daughter
couldn't no no fair enough uh but it was
that was particularly excruciating and
everybody's saying that yesterday went
much better for him because he spoke
about how he was doing it for Megan and
on a sort of emotional level it worked
but on a substantial level or certainly
not at a legal level he didn't provide
anything uh very damning uh he sort of
drew a blank and he has this line that
he likes to say which is
um what's the the pub there's a
difference between the public interest
and what interests the public and I
think he thinks that sounds very clever
well the the Barrister then asked him
well what would be a public interest
story and he drew a blank he couldn't
think of a single one and then he went
and then he said oh a lifetime
threatening injury maybe yes
um and I think that's quite telling of
his mindset that he thinks the only
story that's of public interest about
the Royals is if one of them suffers a
life-threatening injury
um Neil I see you nodding here and
Freddie in his piece you know is almost
competitive therapy which Harry is quite
used to these days but he's treating the
courtroom as a therapy session would you
agree with that
um I think I do I I think what certainly
comes through is that this is a really
damaged guy and he's venting that damage
yeah on something he can focus on so you
know he's had all these years of damage
and he's saying uh that's what's to
blame and that's what he's doing he's
made this into a as your cover story
talks about he's made this into a
crusade because that's the way he's been
able to channel
all his distress and upset that vomiting
out in those excruciating interviews
with Oprah and in this Dreadful book
spare this is sadly a very damaged young
man what he wants to do is and what he's
doing here is he wants to blame the
Press
because frankly that's easier than
actually looking at the issues that
happened in his own life that maybe have
more involvement yeah and he's annoyed
about the scrutiny that the Press put on
him but you know as we were talking
about before we came on air he's
mentioned a lot of individuals in this
court trial probably without consulting
them well I think it's a particularly uh
nasty irony actually I think this is
unpleasant that he talks about his own
um uh privacy being involved
in his one and a half days in the
witness box in his witness statement he
mentions his ex-girlfriend from at least
10 years ago
118 times
Chelsea Davey gets mentioned 118 times
in that document
Chelsea Davey dumped him 10 years ago 12
years ago Chelsea Davey actually got
married and had her first child less
than a year ago
did he ask her permission that he could
destroy her privacy
to complain about his own privacy being
invaded I I literally find that shocking
well I mean it's classic get it with
others
with the spur the book The Manual uh you
know if he didn't tell these people or
he told them at the very last minute
that they'd been mentioned and and so
yeah he doesn't think about the privacy
of others very much but that's one of
the things that I think came through you
mentioned earlier when we were talking
about him turning up a day late
the privilege of his life
he totally ignores he thinks he's got an
absolute right to do whatever he wants
to do so uh he turns up a day late
um and the court can just wait he can
come into this courtroom and
um he can
just say anything he likes it's it was
summed up to me for me by this headline
in today's Daily Mail Barrister are you
aware there is any evidence any evidence
of hacking at all Prince no I mean come
on there is a hundred odd examples here
example and again that in the times for
instance and in this morning's Telegraph
you look and there is fact check whereby
they put up the claim
and oh look it was in the news of the
world the day before they put up the
claim oh it was in an interview he did
with the presser so that he did with the
Press Association
everything is conjecture everything is
tailored by his own desire for it to be
suspicious yeah
to suit his argument and reality Bears
has no connection has it no I think he I
think he should be counting himself
lucky that it's not filmed and recorded
quotes like I don't walk down streets
just seems so utterly bizarre and you
know totally prince Andrew in some ways
um Freddie are you writing your pizza he
doesn't actually seem to have been very
well prepared by his lawyers although
that he was taken on the ride by his
lawyers I mean it does seem like there's
a bit of fear where Harry does he really
know what he's doing he seems like his
legal team are taking him for a ride yes
reading his extraordinary win bag
witness statement uh I kept thinking
what sort of a legal team would that
someone submit this as evidence because
it read like um you know the offcuts
from spare the book you know the stuff
that he didn't really get in there or
his coaster I said it's too it's too
crappy that don't use that uh and I
don't think he's I I mean I think he he
but I think the real story here is that
lawyers have made a lot of money out of
hacking claims uh in the last 10 years I
mean astronomical songs this is
incredible because no hacking has been
found to have been done in the last 10
years so why are they why are the
payouts still going on well there's a
certain amount of relitigating the past
and it's like a lot of things when a big
when big institutions have have been
proven to have done wrong as they have
uh they then have a guilty complex about
and it's much easier just to settle but
they are these tablet the tablet
oppressors are bleeding themselves to
death and they're already dying because
the newspaper industry has suffered a
lot in the last few years yeah for
instance has done something really
interesting about
um these out about the allegations the
time scale of this the truth of the
matter is the first arrest
and the important arrests that stopped
out phone hacking in its tracks was in
August 2006.
since then
The Metropolitan of police have been all
over this they have had hundreds of
officers will work on it for months at a
time so we're effectively talking about
so because the Tabloid press were
completely shocked to discover what they
were doing were illegal they thought it
was iffy but they didn't realize that it
was Criminal
so
we're talking about stuff in terms of
phone hacking that hasn't been happening
for 17 years we're talking about this
talk about you know control the Press
access regulation levison yeah was in
2011 and 2012. that's 10 years ago 11
years ago this is regurgitating material
that is just conjecture some of it is I
mean phone hacking was appalling it was
wrong it was damaging people shouldn't
be punished for it and you can't argue
about that
but what he is talking about and the way
he's talking about it now
is relating to distant history
and Neil you were personally put through
the ringer quite a lot during the time
because you were senior journalists to
add the news of the world uh you were
cleared in 2015 but it was many years of
your life trying to fight this I mean
and now we're in 2023 still talking
about it how do you feel about that
it's eight years
to today
that I was in the dock at the Old Bailey
I've been on bail for uh four years
and I was in the dock at the Old Bailey
fighting for my life for a month and
then 12 good
British people and true found me not
guilty I was innocent
um so
you know I'm I'm sort of pretty well
aware of how this has dragged on yeah
but as far as I'm aware I think I was
the last case that is eight years ago
and so I actually think this is a car
crash uh for British Justice for the
British justice system because this is
actually quite laughable what is
happening here if it wasn't so serious
the Prince Harry in my opinion is
damaging the institution that is the
British legal system because he's using
it and abusing it and you are completely
right when you were talking about the
influence of lawyers keeping this alive
because they have made Millions
and the burden of proof seems to have to
be pretty low you know a lot of these as
you say Freddie tabloids are more
willing to settle out of court than to
fight this in the court so am I writing
thinking that lawyers are you know
bringing out these historical claims
getting a payout and the tablets just
want it to all go away well don't you I
didn't want to get sued for saying this
but it does seem like a money-making
machine uh in many ways
and what what what the lawyers are able
to tap into is is the the grievance that
a lot of celebrities feel often
understandably about their privacy being
invaded But what the celebrities want to
do is convince themselves that they're
changing the world for the better when
actually what they're doing is is trying
to locate their anger at the fact their
privacy as they feel it has been invaded
and we and if they want to change the
media landscape which Harry now says his
life's work uh rather pompously
um what they really need to do is change
the culture because you know people are
purely interested in people's lives and
if you want to stop that then you have
to change the way people think and the
way people are and that's not
necessarily a question for the media and
I would say that the Tabloid culture
that he rails against you know of Diana
the 90s and naughties that also gone now
you know is we've intrude Royal lives in
the same way
yeah uh and the death now for it really
um it started with the tragic death of
Princess Diana because the British
public were appalled by it the another
now went into the coffin with phone
hacking because people didn't mind so
much to be honest that when the phone
hacking was against celebrities
Millie dollar changed everything she was
the girl who uh disappeared turned out
she'd been murdered and there was an
attempt to phone hack her phone by
people who are trying to find out it
where she was because initially she was
thought to be a runaway
um but
the truth of the matter is that the
media landscape has changed Earthly
Freddie in his excellent piece here
talks about falling cascading
um newspaper sales now this was
triggered actually largely by the
internet wasn't it but the sun now
barely sells 700 000 when I worked as
Deputy entered the son
um it sold well over 4 million
you know the Daily Mirror now
runs
if it runs at any kind of profit I will
be surprised at circulation is in a few
hundreds of thousands these it used to
sell two and a half million
so that it's already changed to more
than some effect
and it's a lot to do with the chilling
effect of levison and post hacking post
levison
privacy exploded in in the courts you've
just got a privacy injunction at the
drop about
well I guess Harry is still living in
the past couple quite a lot of this as
well I mean Fred finally do you think
there's a chance that he might win this
case it's a civil case after all uh you
know is there a chance that the judge
decides that that it is plausible that
he was hacked and therefore well because
it's civil not criminal I think that's
possible
um in that because it was interesting in
the witness statement a lot of it what
he was talking about and this is why it
sounded a lot quite whiny a lot of the
times he was talking about the grievance
that he'd felt so I think there is a
quite a possibility that the judge will
find damages because of the hurt that
has been caused to Harry uh but you know
is this as we've discussed this is not
really about phone hacking it's about
feelings uh and that's that's a very
different matter and it's not it's not a
criminal matter
Freddie gray and Neil Wallace thank you
so much for joining spectator TV
in Washington meeting President Biden
for the fourth time this year what's he
hoping to get out of the visit with me
to discuss this and the rest of the week
in politics is our political editor
Katie Bulls
Katie welcome back to spectator TV and
now the Prime Minister Rishi C9 is in
the America uh today as we speak and
he's about to see uh President Biden
what are they going to be talking about
a range of things security trade even
though no one really expects a UK US
trade at any time soon also Ben Wallace
uh the bid for him to be Secretary
General of NATO you can imagine
Michigan to try and use this to do some
a light diplomatic push in favor of the
current defense secretary and then
artificial intelligence which is
something that I think particularly in
the passport right it feels so Downing
Street now really wants to talk about
um and is trying to carve itself a role
on the world stage alongside the us as a
country that will play an important role
on the future of AI and how is the
personal relationship between Biden and
Richard C Knight this is the fourth time
they've met this year but you can't help
but feel that Rishi wants to be friends
more than Biden wants to be friends I
feel this tends to be the case when it
comes to the UK and the US so often the
UK prime minister has seen as looking
quite needy and the U.S Being um perhaps
just a bit too cool for school when it
comes to how how specially they find the
UK prime minister but I think it's
definitely fair to say that if you look
at the previous Prime Ministers and
we'll just go back the past two
um for a work of speed here so Boris
Johnson and Liz Truss It Feels as though
Rishi c-neck has a better foundation for
his relationship with President Biden
but that's partly because he has taken
active steps to get there and the
Windsor framework was clearly something
which
um is at least part aimed at trying to
get America back on side you know Joe
Biden has made lots of comments in the
past about his concerns about the
Northern Ireland protocol about his
concerns about the Northern Ireland
protocol bill which would you know
laterally change parts of it
um under both Boris Johnson and Liz
Truss and this was supposed to be a
resetting moment even though we're yet
of course to return to power sharing and
Stormont
um and I and I think generally
um the style of Russia you see much less
in the way of you know Grand statements
or aggravating phrases there's a certain
way of speaking which Boris Sean
Smithfield's trust would do which could
I think decided to be interpreted by the
us as abrasive whereas Originals much
more mild-mannered now of course well
that really gets you results I think
remains to be seen but I think it's for
those reasons when we're looking ahead
when there are press conferences you
know President Biden it is much less you
know get your popcorn out as it was the
case with the previous that there was
going to be some you know butting of
heads on stage yeah and at least it's
not as bad as Trump and Theresa May was
yes when that was they did hold hands
very awkwardly and Katie back home where
are we at with the covert inquiry then
is the government still fighting against
the inquiry so officially um began this
week
um with the you know opening statement
from Judge Hallett who is leading the
judge that inquire three and but yes as
you point out we're still in a legal
battle between the government and its
own inquiry which is a
interesting way to kick things off and I
think it just points to the level of
discomfort in government about the
inquiry now
something I write about in the magazine
this week is how Richard and of course
inherited this inquiry it was set up
under Boris Johnson and many of those in
Downing Street at the time felt as
though they did need to call an inquiry
he looked at the numbers of deaths
um I think since then there are now
concerns about the is is the scope too
broad we expect this you know evidence
was the final part of the evidence
expected in 2026
and
I think there's some concern too about
the fact that um for example you have
judge Hallett and there are some
government who say well look at some of
her previous judgments
um such as new sensitive material with
MI5 during a 7-7 in quest where she did
not decide about mfo she rejected those
Arguments for their lawyers and it would
suggest that she was someone who would
want the release of lost lots of
documents and so you see a little bit of
blame game in terms of how they've got
to this position and and we'll be
waiting for the the result of the
judicial review but
in a way no matter what happens with
that and I think there's some skepticism
the government will win this isn't
really about the covert messages that is
a basically a legal question about those
um conversations between Witnesses have
been called which are not strictly to do
covered and whether they should be
released whereas the main covert
WhatsApp groups the main code of things
that is already what is being looked at
and I think the question is are we going
to learn anything new is the inquiry
learning lessons in terms of decision
making or if you look at some of the
questions for example submitted to Boris
Johnson should say did you say Let the
Bodies pile high other Witnesses I
understand have been asked did you hear
Boris Johnson say that the body's part
high that is leading to sense
amongstorey MPS this is more about
political Point scoring and catching
ministers at it than perhaps some of the
the bigger questions about was enough
process going to data were views which
were um you know about the cost of
lockdown sufficiently heard and I think
we've got to wait to see if that is
really going to be part of this inquiry
and speaking of Boris Johnson he hasn't
made this process Easy by kind of
stirring the pot a little bit about his
WhatsApp messages and his Diaries and
what's going on there but but it does
seem like Richardson neck is giving him
a bit of an olive branch like sports
being built as an olive branch in a form
of signing off his honors list yeah I
mean so this is the news that we are
expecting Boris Johnson's much awaited
resonation on his list in the next few
weeks and sign up from Rishi soon act
now
I don't think it was ever the case that
richardsonite was going to reject the
honors list
if you look behind the scenes it has
been widely reported including rather
spectator that the original List
released the draft list had over 100
names on it there are reports by the
financial times for the times that
um not number 10 but um I think
officials you know a process which
should not be directly related to
ministers and borussians has slimmed
down the list no comment from Boris
Johnson on this of course there have
been reports that his father Danny
Johnson was on the list at one point
um so so this dog on the list as well
exactly so what what is now being
expected to list around 50 names
um and uh some of those could still be
controversial if it's staff who worked
during party gay and you're getting
honors and let's see if there are family
members on that list
um at this point
um but but I think um it was always
going to be really contentious for every
Sim to actively reject the list that's
not really the precedent for a Tory
prime minister particularly one that
hasn't actually gone to the members
hasn't gone to the public I think it
would be very tricky territory because
question is does Rishi sunak if this
does create a cronyism row and try and
say he's going to change things going
forward is he going to put a cap on the
number he will put on a resignation on
his list There's an opportunity for
Racine to put some clear blue water
between him Boris Johnson still and if
he chooses to take it Katie thank you so
much
time for Britain to cut ties with a
World Health Organization the giant
International Organization seems to have
little idea of what its core mission is
for these days and spends more time
applauding unsavory regimes across the
world than it does on preventing the
next pandemic or at least that's what
Christopher Snowden from The Institute
of economic Affairs argues in this
week's issue he joins me now
so Christopher welcome to spectator TV
now your piece this week is quite a long
charge sheet I think of all the things
that the who gets wrong
um and I hope to get through quite a few
of them um in our interview but first of
all it seems to be one of the major
problems is sucking up to unsavory
regimes yes yes uh they've got a habit
of doing that the charge sheet is very
long but there's only a few examples
really in that in an article
um so yeah the thing that triggered it a
little bit for me was the um putting
North Korea on the executive board
there's only uh eight or nine countries
on the executive board they've got quite
a bit of power to vote for regional
directors and so on and they put North
Korea on there you know and I'm not
saying that countries like North Korea
should be kicked out of the club I
understand that International politics
is a messy business you need to keep
people inside the tent but the who seems
to go beyond that and actively
congratulating some of the worst regimes
around congratulating China on its
covered response saying it was
wonderfully transparent of all things
you know and I think that goes too far
it seems unnecessary and this is just it
happens again and again with The Who and
you just wonder why yeah and so what
about the argument then that some of
these come countries with the worst uh
governments North Korea or China where
it is whatever it is tend to be the
developing countries that the who needs
to have a foothold in as you say you're
not saying about talking about kicking
them out of the club but I kind of kind
of understand why they need to be not
just kicked out but kept quite closely
because who was work should be tackling
developing countries Health Healthcare
Systems
um I I don't think you need to go out of
your way to applaud them and suck up to
me I think that's the difference it
seems to be a feature particularly under
the current director General Dr Tedros
to really cozy up to these organizations
Pat them up on the back applaud them not
put any kind of pressure on them to um
to to reform in any kind of way there
hasn't been any pressure from The Who
for example on China telling us the
truth about you know what happened in
that lab and indeed that inquiry that
they did send over to China was really
quite limited by the Chinese government
yeah it was a fast and then again there
wasn't any Kickback against that but
there's frequent condemnation of Israel
right I mean the same meeting
well what you get is you know it's
countries like Syria and Palestine you
know a lot of the countries around
Israel get together and they'll table
emotion con condemning Israel so you get
Israel constantly condemned North Korea
doesn't get condemned at all in fact it
gets put on the executive board and how
much of this do you think is a problem
of funding China is a who's second
largest funder in the last few years
Donald Trump stopped funding uh the wha
where America used to be the top funders
so it leaves this organization needing
to rely on the funding countries
uh well yeah but I mean the UK
pound-for-pound funds it more than
anybody else and we don't seem to get
anything for that
um yeah per capita but we're easily the
the biggest funder of the who do we use
that soft power in any way to try and
get reform does anybody really try and
use it to get reform we should be
seriously saying
um look if you don't change your ways
then we are going to pull this money and
we should be serious about it and if the
UK doesn't have the stomach around I
don't think it does because it keeps
dishing out more and more money for all
sorts of different things
um some other countries should do it now
that's not a popular thing to say
basically because Donald Trump did it
right Donald Trump for Fairly naked
self-interested political reasons so I'm
going to defund the the the the who
um but just because Donald Trump says
something or does something doesn't
necessarily mean it's a the wrong thing
to do and during covid everybody pretty
much accepted the who had dropped the
ball accepted there was a need for
reform there has been no reform
whatsoever the the real show is doubling
down in all sorts of different ways it's
just being given an extra 20 percent
funding from the member states and as
far as I can see none of those member
states are saying well we'd like to we'd
like to see you clean up your act maybe
we'd like a new director general for
example I mean Dr chandras's judgment is
absolutely appalling you might remember
he tried to appoint Mugabe as Goodwill
Ambassador early on I mean that's just
it's literally incredible it's
unbelievable that anybody would think
that that's a good move a good look and
yet he did it and in a way that
illustrates how broken this organization
is because any other organization on
Earth you would think including probably
even FIFA would say we're not going to
appoint Mugabe as a good will investor
even if we secretly like him for
whatever reason we're not going to do it
but he took an international backlash
for them to rescind that appointment and
what's also interesting is that in the
last few years the who seems to have
changed its focus so moving away from
the infectious diseases that maybe
people associate them with you know as
you say in your article it dines out on
ending smallpox in the world but moving
waterfalls stuff like anti-vaping and
anti-drinking all of these can
non-communicable diseases yeah and I
think that's a problem because I I
really think the who needs to be more
focused in in what it's there for and
really it's there to try and eradicate
infectious diseases to prevent prevent
pandemics to tackle pandemics when they
arise they've shown time again whereas
Ebola zika covid that they're really
flat-footed and surely it can't be
helping that they are diverting so much
of their energy and resources towards
things like announcing people shouldn't
eat artificial sweeteners okay so this
is only a few weeks ago who says
artificial sweeteners uh don't help you
lose weight and cause cancer possibly
now to be fair the evidence on
artificial sweetness is pretty pretty
dodgy like most nutritional epidemiology
but people I think
assume that who is like has the final
word on this because it's a who
we all know what they are it's got a
halo effect they eradicated smallpox but
what actually happens with the who is
when you get any issue which is
scientifically controversial whether
it's artificial sweeteners or vaping or
what have you they don't you know get a
whole load of impartial experts in to
really look at the evidence like a
Cochrane review might do they pick a
side and they get the people from that
side to write a report that's basically
why we know that do we either that's
very often they'll do it anonymously you
still even know who these people are
although often they're British as it
happens and so there's this focus on
sort of Western Nanny State lifestyle
issues partly because of their funding I
mean because they do get funding from
people like Mike Bloomberg as a
billionaire who's fanatically against
vaping and he's a Goodwill Ambassador as
well now
um and they get diverted by the
interests of people in the west because
the West apart from covid-19 haven't
been that interest in infectious disease
because it's not really that big a
problem they're interested in sugary
drinks and alcohol and so on and so you
get these reports coming out from the
who which are really just written by
partisans they're not definitive by any
means and often they're simply wrong
they put out a guide for journalists to
tell journalists how to report an issues
related to alcohol she's just full of
Errors
um so they need to stick to their
knitting as they say they need to focus
on what they do and public health
England had exactly the same problem
they completely dropped the ball on the
pandemic I think largely because they
were obsessed with taking sugar out of
biscuits and telling people to do this
and and you know open a window when it's
a hot day is it also because it's
cheaper to put forward these press
releases on preventative Healthcare
things than it is to actually think
about pandemic prevention where does the
next problem come from I think it's
easier I think that's the thing it's a
lot easier just to go around and tell
governments oh you should be banning
alcohol advertising or you should be
regulating e-cigarettes more stringently
and so on and they feel that's a win
that's something we can come back and
say well we've got this uh we've got
this done but you know with the vaping
especially it's so counterproductive
this is the worst thing about it I mean
vaping as the UK has proven is an
incredibly effective way of getting
people off smoking and the who is advice
to member states and we don't pay much
attention to who advice because we don't
need to but a lot of developing
countries do they don't have their own
health health agencies to and scientists
to really look at the evidence they just
take whatever the who says as gospel and
the wh so who says basically regulate
these things into the dirt if you can't
ban them completely and they you know
this um only a few days ago Ted Ross was
at a press conference got managed to get
onto the subject of e-cigarettes somehow
and said that most kids who try vaping
end up smoking which is just not true
like this you're pretty much the
opposite of the truth right since we've
seen vaping take off even amongst
younger people you know smoking rates
are plummeted so on that particular
issue and a few more what they're doing
isn't just kind of unnecessary and a
waste of money it's actually
counterproductive for public health and
finally Christopher what would you like
to see happen then because you know you
talk about reform and if they didn't
reform the UK should take its money and
walk away but I would think that there's
still a need for some kind of
international Health Organization is it
just too big in its current form is it
is it's funding is not enough what is it
in your ideal world if Christopher
Snowden ran the world and one or two
people even during the pandemic
including David Cameron came up with the
idea of essentially setting up a rival
at World Health Organization that would
be only focused on infectious diseases a
little bit again the parallel with
public health England when Matt Hancock
closed that down he set up the UK Health
Security Agency which he said would be
laser focused on infectious diseases and
so far it has been it hasn't been off
dabbling with the you know ingredients
in biscuits
um it's a pretty good idea because I
think I'm afraid the World Health
Organization is unreformable I don't
think and there's no there's clearly no
will within the organization to to
reform it it is more or less been
trolling the world since covid by doing
things like appointing North Korea and
coming up all these ridiculous
announcements and telling
um telling schools that they should be
teaching toddlers about masturbation you
know this insane stuff
um it seems to me they almost want to be
closed down we can't close them down we
shouldn't close them down overnight
obviously but I think the idea of
setting up some rival organization which
will eventually out compete the who with
pandemic preparedness
um I think that's probably the way
forward and if people like Bill Gates
and less likely Mike Bloomberg put their
money into that kind of thing
um that that's a very real possibility
and that could happen in a relatively
short period of time without any
destruction I would say very interesting
Christopher Snowden thank you so much
for joining spectator TV
next recently the telegraph revealed
that the British government had not won
but two separate units designed to
monitor online content for discussions
surrounding the pandemic it meant that
the posts of high profile lockdown
Skeptics people like Oxford's car
Hennigan were flagged by the government
to social media companies as
misinformation you can just imagine the
cycling effect on diversity debate
during that pandemic
Free Speech campaigners are arguing that
this is a pattern across the world that
censorship is not just a problem limited
to authoritarian States one of them is
with me now the author and journalist
Michael schellenberger
so Michael your campaign to promote
freedom of speech first came about from
the Twitter files in the United States
but is now rolled out to a global
campaign can we just start with in your
eyes what is the problem what's happened
to Freedom or speech right now well what
we're looking at is a a very interesting
and disturbing simultaneous Crackdown on
Free Speech that's happening across the
English speaking world it's happening in
the UK in the United States Canada New
Zealand Australia it's also happening in
Brazil very aggressively but we also see
the European Union preparing to impose
new regulations on speech in all these
cases they're they're offering uh
seemingly benign or benevolent reasons
for this but these are very serious
measures that are being put in place
that are aimed at censoring people
online and it comes in the context of
Revelations that both the United States
the the UK and and many of these other
countries have in fact been pressuring
social media companies to to censor
disfavored views and even display D
platform disfavored users and so it's
really I think one of the most
significant threats to freedom of speech
uh certainly since the creation of the
internet and and perhaps over the last
hundred years and I think it's one of
those things that might have just gone
under the radar especially for people
who don't maybe spend much time on
social media but you know I just want to
start by talking to you about the
Twitter files which is the story that
you are one of the main journalists
reporting on it Elon Musk the new CEO of
Twitter gave you these files and what do
they reveal well the the first thing
that we discovered the Twitter files was
much of what people had suspected which
is that it's a very Progressive
left-wing staff at Twitter and they were
censoring uh views mostly of
conservatives on a range of topics but
we quickly then discovered the
involvement and a significant amount of
communications from U.S government
officials as well as with U.S government
contractors that were urging censorship
of specific views so the most dramatic
was around the 2020 elections and around
the 2021 campaign to basically uh fight
any resistance or concerns around
vaccines and so some of the most
dramatic evidence has come out from a
separate uh set of documents that were
done by a lawsuit for the attorney's
General of Missouri and Louisiana where
we had officials in the White House
effectively bullying Facebook staff to
censor
uh people's experiences with vaccine
side effects and these were often true
these were true uh vaccine side effects
and they were censoring them anyway
because they worried that it would
create hesitancy around taking the
vaccine so what we saw was a very
similar approach uh between what
happened here in the United States what
happened in Britain with the lockdown
files where you saw uh Hancock I believe
is the name of your government Minister
who emailed and had correspondence with
Nick Clegg also a former UK government
official who is now who's then at
Facebook very very similar Dynamic here
in the United States but we've basically
seen this on a range of issues ranging
from election to covid climate change
and the one of the latest things that
we've seen is people uh really trying to
drum up this idea that there's been an
increase of hate speech there's no
evidence for that and or of hateful
incidents in fact there's a lot of
evidence that people are just expanding
their definition of what hateful speech
is and so we now see basically different
excuses or predicates being offered by
government officials and government
contractors for greater social media
censorship
yeah and you say that this is a global
problem because on the question of hate
speech I believe there's a bill going
through uh the Irish uh legislative at
the moment which would basically
designate a lot of things as hate speech
um to have that same chilling effect
that you're talking about yeah the Irish
uh legislation is quite shocking in how
frankly totalitarian it is it allows
police to go into people's homes
unannounced uh to look for so-called
hateful material on their computers and
phones without a warrant it it presumes
guilt in other words if you have those
materials that are deemed hateful
materials you're presumed that you were
going to disseminate them some of the
censorship demands have have been seen
strategic such as trying to stop uh
vaccine hesitancy other kinds of
censorship demands we've seen have been
very Petty and have been by politicians
who are upset that they're being
criticized in social media and so I sort
of smile because it seems slightly
ridiculous but if you're familiar with
some of the mentality of politicians or
elected officials often that is the
level at which their brains are
operating but that's kind of precisely
the forms of speech that we should allow
first and foremost I mean arguably the
most important kinds of speech are the
kinds criticizing our elected leaders
since we need to properly criticize them
and have a debate about them in order to
decide who to elect of course and and
bringing it back to the UK as well um
you know Michael you mentioned uh those
Hancock Files The Spectator was very
much covering that we spoke to the
journalist who leaks those is about
oakshot who was his Ghost Writer at the
time and recently we've heard from uh
journalism done by the telegraph about
these two government units within
British government that during the
pandemic was basically monitoring social
media content flagging the ones that are
basically against the mainstream whether
it's on vaccines or on lockdown or
anything else to social media companies
as well so I absolutely agree with you
that it does seem to be happening here
as well but what do you say to people
who think that actually especially
during a time like the pandemic when the
science is not clear that actually
tackling disinformation and
misinformation is incredibly important
and that actually this is people getting
it wrong in the in the margins but the
idea of not perfect freedom of speech on
online platforms especially during a
time when people's lives are at risk you
know it's no bad thing you know we have
to calm down on conspiracy theory so it
depends on where you draw that line
yeah and they're they're I think it's
important to keep in mind that the word
and concept of disinformation comes out
of militaries and it's been uh all
governments um engage in disinformation
campaigns against foreign adversaries uh
I think we all agree that we do not want
our government engaging in
disinformation campaigns against us
um we know that governments getting
engaged in uh their own public relations
or propaganda but obviously we don't
want to be victimized by disinformation
campaigns the problem is that what
happened at least in the United States a
very clear shift is that you started to
see it even in the discourse of the
people advocating censorship is they
started to say well really the
disinformation isn't coming as much from
the Russians anymore it's really coming
from American citizens well that's a way
of saying that they disagree with things
that American citizens are saying but
when you call it disinformation it
suggests a nefarious motivation that
people are deliberately lying and
certainly people people do deliberately
lie and we all have laws against
committing fraud for example but really
what was being classified in some cases
is just disagreement and in other cases
it was people sharing their personal
experience of vaccine side effects that
they genuinely had
in um the one of the principles that we
have of free speech is that we think
it's a fundamental right to be able to
say what you believe we have a
fundamental right to be wrong
in fact being wrong is often a part of
being right it's that debate is
important for societies to get questions
right so in the middle of a pandemic is
precisely the time when you would want
to have Divergent voices you would also
want to have government saying uh no
these things are not true or they are
true but what you don't want is the
government in a position where it's
disallowing that debate and so the
vaccine example is very important I mean
there was a lot of effort to require
pharmaceutical companies to list the
side effects of their pharmaceutical
drugs in their advertising that was
considered a very important Progressive
Victory so to have the government
demanding that social media platform
censor information about the side
effects of drugs or pharmaceutical uh
interventions is quite chilling and
disturbing and it I think that it may
mean that there would be more vaccine
hesitancy but that's I think a small
price to pay for protecting our freedom
of speech and and I think look in that
particular case I I was I think that the
consensus and I certainly was vaccined I
was vaccinating myself and boosted so
I'm not an anti-vaxxer by any means but
I do think that the uh there were some
populations that did not need to have
the vaccine and um they should have been
been allowed to have that debate and
have that concern in fact one of the
things that we saw censored by Twitter
was a Harvard Professor named Martin
kildorf who's actually assuming the US
government right now for saying that not
everybody necessarily needs the vaccine
that's actually a fairly mainstream View
at this point but in the pandemic it was
one of the things that was censored and
indeed an Oxford Professor called Carr
Hennigan who was Raising questions about
the effectiveness of face masks and a
contributed to spectator was flagged
down for some of his content that he did
with a spectator as well
um and finally Michael what would you
like to see be done here because in my
mind it seems to me a lot of the problem
here comes down to Big Tech working hand
in glove with government when these big
techs tend to lean liberal or left-wing
whatever you want to call it and they're
unelected and that is a problem it's
also a problem that their public forums
in a way that everyone simply uses them
Free Speech we're talking about is a lot
of it's digital Free Speech these days
but what is the way to tackle that
without also kind of going too far the
other direction of making uh the
internet a lawless place there has to be
some level of content moderation I think
you would agree so what would you like
to be CB done
well I think the most important thing is
that I think countries should have free
speech protections that are as strong as
we have in the United States we have the
First Amendment to our constitution
provides very broad protections we do
not allow a government agency to be
involved in regulating speech I think
most people across the Western World and
really all over the world would like to
have that American free speech standard
and there is a proposal in Britain uh to
to reform your laws so that the British
system is much closer to the American
system and um so I think that's the most
important thing we want we want to help
people around the world and that's why
we're coming to London June 22nd to the
23rd to bring people from around the
world that would like to have stronger
free free speech Protections in their
own countries even in the United States
we saw this effort which was by the
Department of Homeland Security to
basically create
ngos to engage in the censorship work
even though the ngos were government
funded they had to try to do a
workaround because of the awareness of
the first amendment in Britain it was
the counter disinformation unit that was
a government unit that unit in my view
if I were British I would not want that
unit to exist I would rather not have a
government speech entity in terms of the
social media platforms there is a
variety of them the two most important
are obviously Twitter and Facebook and
arguably Twitter is even more important
because of the amount of information
density and the potential of the
technology to allow speech to go viral
we're in the midst of a lot of pressure
that's on the owner of Twitter to censor
people even more
some of it's coming from government some
of it's coming from corporations
I have personally and publicly
encouraged Elon Musk to make transparent
all censorship decisions that have to do
with you know social and political
issues I mean getting rid of Channel
child pornography is not controversial
but I think when he is asked for example
as he was by the Turkish government and
it really required by the courts to
engage in censorship I think he did the
right thing by publishing the government
requests on Twitter as well as the
Twitter accounts that they want to have
censored so there I think there is
um governments should not they cannot
require social media platforms to
communicate certain things that's also a
violation of our freedom
um and that you can't have a government
regulator that is focused on getting
involved in the day-to-day content
moderation and censorship decisions of a
platform like Twitter but I do think
governments can require that social
media platforms be transparent about
those censorship decisions that they're
making they can immediately report what
they're doing and I think there should
be a place for some appeal of those
censorship Decisions by individual users
so that if they're being censored then
at least there's a public discussion
about their censorship and I would also
then have a mandate that all government
officials that ever ask for anything by
the social media companies whether it's
the promotion of speech or the
censorship of speech also be immediately
required to make that public it could be
done very easily through an automated
email system that would that would allow
people to see what those demands were
and what the levels of compliance by the
social media companies were
very interesting Michael schellenberger
thank you very much and you're coming to
Westminster on June 22nd so viewers at
home want to catch Michael Matt taibi
and Russell Brand you can do that there
thanks Michael and we have a new offer
for the selectator magazine if you
subscribe to The Spectator today you'll
get your first month completely free and
after that you'll just pay one pound a
week for full access to our website and
app or two pounds a week if you want the
print magazine cheap to claim this offer
go to spectator.co.uk forward slash best
and finally an odd video was released by
Oxfam this week have a watch
how are you marking pride month this
year while lgbtqia plus people around
the world are deprived of basic safety
not protected by laws
prayed on my hate groups online and
offline
what was purportedly a positive video in
support of the LGBT community had one
illustration of so-called turfs it
wasn't long before viewers pointed out
that this looked remarkably like the
author JK Rowling
Oxfam quickly took down the video and
re-uploaded an edited version with that
particular screen taken out
is it really the role of Charities like
Oxfam to be wading in on a debate
surrounding trans rights well I'm joined
now by the journalist Helen Joyce
well that's quite something isn't it
hell in that video um thank you so much
for joining us today what were your
First Reactions when you saw that I
looked at it and I thought that this is
in the long tradition of disgusting
bigoted propagandistic videos attacking
human rights activists so if you look
back you can see uh people who were
campaigning to keep slavery doing
paraproogic pictures of black people
with you know animalistic features and
big thick characters yeah and then you
you go forward a bit and you see the
suffragists and the suffragettes
caricatured as you know harridons with
padlocks through their mouths you know
with the captions saying she wants the
votes in this idiotic stupid woman and
then a bit further forward you know the
in during the Civil Rights Movement or
you look at pictures of Jews with big
hook noses looking like goblins and now
we've got again we've got women's rights
campaigners being caricatured to look
like vile shrews dried up paradigms
witches witches absolutely witches it is
just not plausible yeah to see this any
other way than a way to denigrate women
who are trying to speak up for women's
rights
the badge Turf on it as well I mean just
Helen just tell viewers what that term
means in case anyone doesn't doesn't
know your number well it's short for a
trans-exclusionary radical feminist but
it's a ridiculous term because very few
people are radical feminists and nobody
is trans-exclusionary what what women
are doing is they're saying that male
and female are real categories
and that female people's rights do on
occasion require the recognition of
those being real categories and
excluding males yeah so there are places
that I would exclude all males from and
it wouldn't matter whether they're trans
identified or not and I don't regard
myself as a radical feminist so it's
just like saying you know
I don't know Global Elites or something
when you mean you you know it's it's
just a front word it's a slur it's a
front word
um and there's no way people say well
it's just uh it's just an acronym but
that's like saying you know the four
letter shortening of Pakistani is just a
shortening of Pakistani or that you know
the n-word is just a mispronunciation of
negro which is what people used to call
black people these are not plausible
slurs are proved by the way they're used
and this isn't the first time that Oxfam
has taken the sand on gender issues back
in March they told their staff to avoid
using potentially offensive terms such
as mothers and fathers now I didn't know
that with those words for offensive
terms well anything that indicates that
there are two Sexes is now offensive
because we're meant to be entirely
focused on people who deny that fact and
who also aren't happy with their own sex
so I distinguish those two groups there
are trans people who aren't happy being
the sex that they are and some of them
are quite realistic about that they know
what their sex is they know it makes
them unhappy they're perfectly easy and
nice to talk to and then there's other
ones who want the whole world broken to
fit them back into the sex category that
they're not
and then there's a much larger penumbra
of people who think of themselves as
allies for whom it's extremely important
to deny the fact that there are two
Sexes and so those are the people who
are destroying women's rights destroying
children's education are destroying gay
people's rights because you counter
sexual orientation without sex they're
willing to break absolutely everything
in order that some men can count as
women and some women can count as men
one of the
Turf doesn't work as a term is because
you you're not actually trans
exclusionary but you did say you know
you would exclude trans people from
certain areas male trans people from
female yeah but female people who are
trans identified of course they're
welcoming so it's just about male and
female I don't even care really about
trans or trans identification I care
about the actual real categories male
and female in particular I'm a
campaigner for female people's rights
which do require us to be able to draw
boundaries can you understand about
Oxfam might be coming from here they
took the video down initially and then
they've what have they said about it so
they took it down because there's a
scene in this that cannot possibly
plausibly be denied to be based on JK
Rowling so there's you know there's this
picture of this shrewish witch-ish
looking woman wearing a dress that's
very like a particular picture of JK
Rowling with a particular badge that JK
Rowling's wearing actually a poppy
turned into the Tariff badge I don't
know for sure but I would be surprised
if they didn't get a call from some
libel lawyers as soon as the video went
up so they took it back down
um and they took that out and as far as
I know they put it back up but I also
have seen because it's been published on
Twitter
um the internal email that they sent to
All staff about it in which they said
that this was a procedural error and
that and they accept that gender
critical beliefs are protected under UK
law which they are ever since Maya 4
status case
and that means that you can't you can't
be so bigoted against people who believe
that sex is real as they just have been
but then they go on to say it's very
difficult to
um combine the belief that sex is real
with other people feeling that that
attacks their identity and they come
down pretty hard on the side of the
identity they they say that in any staff
who've been upset by all of this
pushback against the video can call and
get counseling and there's trauma
services and all the usual that
we do nowadays whenever anyone claims to
be offended and that they are proud of
their um their trans allyship and they
continue to celebrate it and so on and
so forth honestly this email was sent
out in the UK by someone senior in
oxfam's UK officers I wouldn't be
surprised if that email just continues
to repeat the um discrimination against
oxfam's gender critical staff I'd be
interested to hear what an employment
lawyer said about it yeah very
interesting and then they've put the
video back up but without that uh
reference that scene referencing well
but can you see where um Oxfam and other
companies um who kind of go into the
space are coming from you know it's
pride month this month you know LGB a
holy month of Pride yes the holy month
of Pride LGBT people are some of the
most marginalized people around the
world especially for you know when an
organization like Oxfam which works in
developing world so much you know they
are marginalized people and I don't
think we would deny that trans people
have a difficult time in a lot of
society but so can you see where they're
coming from when they say that we want
to show some kind of solidarity as I
understand that your position is more
it's where those trans rights come in
conflict with the women's rights that's
the problem we shouldn't automatically
give the former priority but trans
people do have a tough time in society I
think if you think about what Oxfam was
set up to do which is to feed women and
children in disaster zones
I'm sorry I'm not willing to bend over
backwards to the extent that you're just
bending over backwards LGBT people do
have a tough time women and children
also have a tough time oxtime is meant
to be working in the developing world
and it's the majority of its donations
come from women the people whose staff
it's charity shops around the world are
middle-aged and elderly women who by and
large like as in almost all of them will
completely agree with JK Rowling stance
on all of this and are doing this work
because they care about the women who
die in childbirth they care about the
children who are starving they care
about the innocent victims of war
earthquake famine Etc so no I don't I
don't bend over backwards on this and I
say this as the mother of a gay son and
he'd agree with me you know their focus
should be on the half of humanity women
yeah who are the innocent victims in
these situations they should be thinking
about mothers they should be thinking
about babies and they've lost their
husbands
it's just you know once you start down
this Rabbit Hole of thinking that you
know men are the world's most
marginalized people as long as those men
think they're women you've lost all
touch with reality and you turn yourself
180 degrees around from what your
original Mission was and you start
talking this sort of nonsense and then
you end up producing bigger to
propaganda like this and finally had it
I mean so many of these issues are
coming to afford because of
organizations where the corporate or
charity trying to get in on this uh on
this movement you know Bud Light and
Nike recently in America you know had
dinner Mulvaney as one of the
advertising and had massive backlash so
are you heartened by the fact that
shareholders and consumers seem to be
pushing back at this being kind of
shoved down their throats
the beginning of the fight back honestly
because this stuff has been embedding in
corporate culture for so long and you
have to remember corporations I mean
they're a moral creatures they do
whatever they think is easiest for them
and there's a big fashion at the moment
for virtue signaling which it doesn't go
very well with being profit driven so if
you're told that you have to be
environmentally friendly and you have to
be focused on EDI Equity diversity and
inclusion you're not going to think you
know how do we support disabled staff
how do we make sure that mothers are
able to get back to work you know could
we help care leavers to get jobs with us
those would all be excellent things to
do but actually hard you're looking for
the cheapest most visible the most yeah
cheap and visible you know putting the
trans flag on your website saying
something about pride month forcing
everyone to put pronouns in their email
signature and uh you know telling people
that the words mother and father are
bigoted
Helen Joyce thank you so much for
joining us spectator TV you're very
welcome
that's it for this week
once again thank
you New Wealth Management for sponsoring
the week in 60 minutes canacode will
provide you with the expertise you need
to help build your wealth with
confidence
visit candywealth.com for more
information
thanks again for watching and do join us
next week
[Music]
thank you